it's okay so why are women looked at as
oppressed throughout history when men
were the ones that had to go to war and
women were protected and got to stay
home
that she just
trust me she does it all the time
did you know that women when they asked
for the what the majority of women
didn't want the right to vote
because that meant you had to get
drafted
and let me tell you in 2022 if i had to
pick if i had to give up my right to
vote and my other option was drafted
i would give it up
i'm not trying are you trying to fight
an award no i'm gonna play no i don't
know if i can say that on youtube
i'm a scaredy cat by oh my god though no
i'm i'm not no i'm like get back to the
i'll be in the kitchen yep i
as crazy as it sounds i would be like
i'll stay at home i'll cook and clean
wash everything
do whatever you want just don't send me
to war yep exactly but um also when you
look at it with the war and everything
you know
i'm not going to go into a specific day
i can't remember but i do remember that
once there was men that went to war
and
the women were the one who actually got
the community and the environment back
together which made women
more powerful than a man
yeah i'm sure there's some societies
that's happened in
yeah because even when you look at it
now
some men look at women as oh you can't
do this job because it's just for men
oh i do
you do yeah i think that
yeah a lot of people just look at it as
what is she doing here like if a woman
decides to go work at the oil rig or do
construction or just do manly stuff
they're just
not looked at as the same anymore oh i
just i don't think women are capable of
doing a lot of hard jobs
like i and i i the the reason i think
this is because i have numbers to back
it up like the those industries are 99.5
male
and i don't i don't think it's because
women want to do them i think it's
because they're like dear god please no
an oil rig
anyone else oh my gosh it's the worst
place to work for me yeah
i don't even think most men want to do
those jobs no not at all but i mean most
men would just go after the most money
yeah even if it's worth risking their
lives
but i think that's that's that's just
something innate in men because you guys
always have to provide for us yeah no
matter what just like women always had
to nurture the children
and so it's interesting because if you
look at countries where um
where they they listed countries from
the most free to the least free when it
comes to women it's pretty easy to do
that because you take like places like
the middle east um i know saudi arabia a
couple years ago like women couldn't
drive and you take the most egalitarian
countries in the world like norway um i
think was one of them but you know what
i'm saying like the most where they've
taken the most measures for women to be
free and it's interesting because the
pay gap it increases in the free
countries and decreases in the least
free countries because when women are
given the option to choose they pick
jobs that have to do with people and
those don't tend to pay as much
it's true yeah that's very true yeah
like who t and it's funny because we'll
march the streets because women don't
they
they're not in the one percent right but
what about only fans why aren't we
marching the streets for equality
strippers models
kendall jenner makes too much money yes
hey pay the men the same
crickets
right but it's interesting because it's
like it seems like sometimes we only
march the streets when it doesn't
benefit us but we never advocate for men
i agree 100
do you think that there should be a um
uh
a men's support group
cool i feel like it shouldn't
you feel like they shouldn't they should
women support group and also with that
being said is that the right word
i think you mean men's shelters are you
in the menstrual support group
no it was a
okay yeah
i was just making sure i was right i
don't want to be out here walking yeah
okay go ahead yeah just as um
with the kendall jenner the male models
and the female models i feel like
everyone should be paid
for the hard work that they put in not
because you're more beautiful
more gorgeous than you work the runway
men do it too men look good men look
gorgeous as well
i feel like everyone should be paid
equally just for the work you put in to
the job when it comes to that kind of
thing
you know
i feel like it's pretty unfair on their
behalf because
it's more look that like
i've done so much work so much more than
what this person have put into yet
they're still getting paid like what is
the difference
so so question so i i i do my channel
right and let's say i had merch and i
wanted to pay you both to model for me
for merch
if when she wears my shirt my
sweatshirts i sell
50 and when you wear my sweatshirts i
sell 10. should i still pay you the same
i mean
like the work because
looking at it is like
it depends on how you sell the product
so
if she looks good in your product it's
more likely to sell than a men debt yeah
that doesn't yeah so i guess it's the
same for the modeling situation because
women tend to sell a product more
well i just like it's funny because when
you start like hiring people you kind of
understand like the employer's point of
view and so if if you're not making me
money
then i like why would i pay you more you
know what i mean like like if the girls
pa making me money of course i'm gonna
pay her more
and that's a group
so
that's like why you see um in like the
one percent too
because more men are willing to work 80
hours a week for like 40 years not me it
couldn't be me no yeah most men aren't
going to do it either but like of course
they're going to pay the men more
because more men are going to do it and
yeah they're more men are going to be
good at it because most girls want
like it's a long time most girls are
like you know i'm going to start a
family i'm good yeah
now you were saying about modeling there
are areas where men
don't
get paid um the same as women but you
don't hear
men saying
oh we want equal rights we we don't want
to pay gap in these areas in these areas
they just they don't say nothing so why
do you think women
put substitute infinite emphasis on
things like that when it really there
really isn't one there's just
things that are
innate in
um
females and innate and men that make men
more viable to have those
top earners and like ceo positions so
why do you think women
um go so hard for a pay gap because they
probably feel like they're more
deserving
than a man
getting
you know more money how so if
say say we get um
how can i best explain this
say
you're you're a ceo and i'm uh
i don't know what's a step down from a
ceo we have the same degrees and
everything i actually know let's say
we have the same degree same um
application everything
um but you get paid more and i get paid
less
there is what i was talking about
there's things that are innate and men
and innate and women you're going to get
paid more because
of just
they want somebody that can negotiate
that's not going to be
more
agreeable with somebody that's going to
get the job done and that's just
something that's biological in men and
when i heard that the first time i was
like
well
why can't
women
learn how to do that
but that would be
considered
turning into a man because i asked pearl
that i said well why can't women learn
how to be more masculine to get these
positions
but it would be
more
when they act more masculine
that's
less valuable to a man in a sense so you
would get it because you have traits
that
are viable to the company and its
success
and i wouldn't get that does that make
sense so it's not
oh i'm not getting as much money because
i'm a woman
it's that i don't have the qualities to
get this job done and that's just
something that's innate in me
yeah i agree definitely about getting
the job done
more than just like i need to get more
money yeah
is that right pearl
yeah okay she is red pill no i'm scared
don't say that no oh my gosh i like she
it's funny because she didn't know any
of this stuff like
i don't know two three months ago but
now it's like she could recite it it's
so funny to oh goodness to see the
evolution
you know what's interesting we're
talking about body count earlier
if you're a virgin what's your chance of
a happy marriage as a girl
i don't know
i mean
i'm not so i don't know i don't know
eighty percent ah guess what it is after
five partners
i was able to say 10 but no
it's higher than
oh 10. oh wow
thirty percent oh i was like 25
i thought it was 25 i said that earlier
it's actually 30. that is mad see
i'll be back there
be
careful child
all right
[Music]
and so
with that little snippet of information
would you
um
do you think you would have done things
differently
to
be able to be in that on that pathway
essentially i don't think so no you
would i would just
yeah i wouldn't have changed
are those the right ones
would you oh my god yeah yeah i would
you would yeah
i wanted to wait till i was married same
if i could if i could go back and change
it i would i would still be a virgin to
this day yeah me too
i don't know
she's like [ __ ] too fun
can't give that up he said i don't want
to ride i want to run i mean i i would i
would have waited but i think
i think i just
it was the moment
at that moment i was like you know what
i'm gonna eventually do it anyway so it
was like so i don't think i would have
like
waited i mean i've waited a lot i didn't
lose it like
what is the average age that someone
would lose it i'm guessing like 16. okay
i lost it when i was what 20 okay same
so i
i was gonna it was gonna eventually
happen yeah
when am i
like when am i gonna get married like
what when i'm 80
yeah
like yes no you're not
you have 10 more years to live oh no
that's all just another thing though
another thing with people not waiting is
only because
they don't know when it is going to
happen
people are more impatient these days to
be waiting for
someone to come along instead of just
going to explore your options some women
just like men exported options to know
what and what they don't like in women
or just to just have fun some women
rather do go and explore their options
but not as much as a man would in order
for them to say okay i would rather
settle down with this man and make
things right
but
who knows you know
well yeah i do think it's a lot because
i do remember being 20 and being like
when am i going to meet my husband
are you sure at 20 or like 8 years old
you have a dream of just getting married
and just having like 20.
what seven i was like yeah but i i don't
know 18 i'm moving out 20 i'm gonna be
married 25 i'm gonna have kids
none of those
i said that at 25 i was going to have
kids have five years with just me and my
husband actually i think i said
i said like 20
no i said five years with me and my
husband and then 30 i would have kids
well
here i am